c'est une maîtresse d'école a dit à ses
élèves qu'est ce que vous aimeriez à
avoir tiens-toi venoix qu'est ce que tu
aimerais avoir dû me nouant avec la
famille on est en appartement moi
j'aimerais bien avoir une maison j'ai
des potes qu'on une maison ils ont un
jardin une table de ping pong à barbecue
ouais ça doit être sympa et toi qu'est
ce que témoin à avoir jamais moi
j'aimerais bien avoir comme jeu de potes
qui ont une maison de campagne
c'est génial on respire la merde toute
la semaine dans la pollution
et puis le week-end ils partent et tout
à coup ils vont à la pêche il voit la
nature les oiseaux j'aimerais bien avoir
une maison de campagne
et toi marius que c'est moi avoir lieu
m'aurait on a tous sinon on a tous la
maîtresse elle un peu intrigué c'est un
quartier populaire quand même dit
comment ça vous avez tout douze jours ma
grande soeur elle est rentrée à la
maison avec un noir mon père dit tiens
il nous manquait plus que ça
[Rires]
mais la toile bateau est ce que tu as
déjà vu une tomate chanter donc moi j'ai
déjà vu une carotte râpée
[Applaudissements]
enfin voulu mais ça les enfants
voulaient bien matt carottes quand vous
offrait à l'oignon fait moi aussi j'ai
d'une munition vous vous appelle titre
c'est pour la bonne cause
mais c'est pour la battle pas si je
résume boulanger 6 mi-temps d'un donne
asile faisant monsieur non on n'a pas de
tarte pour nom n'a pas dit samba demain
il ya donc voir ou non non je disais
d'hier ont fait un topo reviennent ça et
tu es copains il ya quinze mois nous
n'avons rien fait non non à battre à
tokyo on abat deux cartes au port au
pied des voies la fesci ils sont quand
même une quinzaine et tient à son mari
comme le bon ça y est la demande faite
au bol qui en voulait trouver trentaine
de tarte aux pommes toute la nuit fille
trop beau et plus tard de mo williams
est à nouveau aimer
du balai
[Rires]
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
alors que dit matthew patton poireau est
d'accord on arrive à bout
op
sur l'ognon tout à l'heure vous
inquiétez pas pour l'instant on est
encore dans les légumes propres d'accord
vous inquiétez pas maintenant c'est une
offre qui est en tête de cette deuxième
battle louis alors bon un arabe
alors là donc ça milite algériens qui
ont
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
habitués et tu les as tu as je les adore
j'ai envie de le lasser le mot alors
cinq minutes algérien qui revient de sa
caserne parce qu'ils avaient envie de sa
femme dont il demande à son commandant
trois jours de congés son commandant lui
donne trois jours de congés il arrive
chez lui il s'aperçoit que sa femme est
indisposé lui se comprendre car elle
disposait donc il est dégoûté du foot à
comment je vais faire et tout c'est pas
comme en affaires et il faut que je
trouve une solution est tout il va
appeler son commandant mais il ya toute
sa famille sa belle famille chez lui du
coup il va parler à son commandant avec
des termes un peu militaire et donc
qu'il appelle son commandant et dit oui
commandant ici oméga aux problèmes en
bas attaque alerte rouge prolonger congé
alerte rouge en bas prolongé le congé et
son commandant et lui répond directement
ai dit oui ici oméga en juillet oméga
ans je vous entends oui oui oui attaqué
par derrière ovni immédiatement
[Applaudissements]
je crois que ça joue autres tito
ferrasse après ce voyage à fiat fait la
photo la bataille malian alors non
jeanne moreau va vous raconter une
blague d'accord alors c'est l'histoire
d'un homme extraordinaire qui est un
chien magnifique et ils se promènent
jardin du luxembourg et son chien
vraiment il sait tout faire c'est un
très beau chiffre est à chaque fois que
quelqu'un ne croise en effet lui dit
mais qu'est ce qui est beau votre petit
chien et sa palier ou qui louent qui ont
qui s'est offert you qui lève la patte
il lève la loue qui lève la patte gauche
élèves la patrie ou qui croient ce n'est
pas un croisé ou qui tourne comme ça
sont en l'air le chien fait tout est à
ce moment là rien très beau jeune homme
qui passe comme ça et le maître dit donc
lyon qui est maintenant c'est ce
monsieur fillon qui suce le monsieur bon
justement trouvé c'est la dernière
[Applaudissements]
ce côté là je vous donne ma première
c'est que c'est quoi je suis l'homme tu
es le talent du canada une série qui
fait non mais si si ça les histoires
dont tous adhérents sont fourbes et c1
coupe à la femme elle est dans le lit
comme ça à l'hôpital c'est son vieux
tous les deux elle a des perfs elle a
des machins masquer son mari villa lui
tient la main d'où un moment donné elle
pousse un peu mince que c'est mon amour
mon amour
il fait oui qu'est-ce qu'il ya qu'est-ce
qu'il ya l'amour de ma vie qu'est-ce
qu'il fait écoute j'ai une dernière
chose à demander une dernière chose
avant de partir il fait tout ce que tu
veux mon amour tout ce que tu veux je
ferai tout ce que tu veux
il y fait moins l'amour une dernière
fois avec ce fut moi ça va pas enfin
machine est à l'hôpital tient des fils
partout des matins des trucs pas
possibles effets moi l'amour je t'en
supplie fait moi je mourrai dernière
fois une dernière fois et certains ports
il prend la porte mais ni chézy clic
bloque la porte
et puis monte sur le lit doucement avec
beaucoup de tendresse il commençait à
faire l'amour avec sa frappe
à ce moment là il ya le rouge qui monte
aux joues elle est là elle est au mieux
de plus en plus heureuse c'est
merveilleux il faut la moss est sublime
c'est extraordinaire matin et ça se
termine en apothéose et les là en pleine
forme est là les perfs en balance les
chicken déchire le vase
elle fait bien on se tire gens en pleine
forme et lui reste sur le lien en
laminant l'amf est question d'amour
quand je pense que j'ai bu sovema m
[Rires]
il est lancé un magazine
moise c'est un enfant qui joue au train
électrique et donc ils commencent à
jouer au train électrique et son kit
rhin effet choo choo choo gare de
montpellier garde [ __ ]
et il continue to guard du var que des
cônes à sa mère elle commence à me
regarda n'en peut plus et wii continue
vetcho chucho gare de lyon gares de cons
ça m'a vraiment plu sa vulgarité à
dimont vas-y tu prends contrat
électricté puni le puits dans sa chambre
pendant trois heures au bout d'un moment
a dit bon on va lever la punition elle
va chercher les bancaires en clair la
punition tu peux tu peux retourner jouer
le pied reprend sont réels effets chocs
yacht show gare de montparnasse trois
heures de retard à cause d'une kaunas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
petit a alors cédé dernier ils font là
ou alors on est d'accord qu'on sait
c'est familial d'aironi et des maps non
plus en quoi faire les fous du à l'étagé
du temps et boucherie au passage une
saucisse je m'attache 6 à la saucisse et
un pantalon loin de payer
jean la saucisse tu te baisse j'ai fait
ça me met un peu de magie à saucisse
photo do on part sans payer vu amputer
rhône est un génie merci les gars aussi
sûrement le matin j'ai déjà fait trois
îles vanille un pastis de passer
histoire pas se mouiller notre humain
bon il faut payer antilles puis soit
ceci si j'ai eu des moments ils se
marrent 60 chaînes
trois bars quatre bars simard au nom
d'un des déchets hornish un peu plus là
c'est bon quoi
denoix saucisson en échange la saucisse
ça fait au moins c'est marc que j'ai
perdu
[Applaudissements]
avec ces mets d ali savez que je suis né
en tunisie
oui c'est que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
d'amis d'enfance moi je suis juif arabe
et puis moi j'ai des copains qui sont
des arabes musulmans et est donc si
mohamed ali et mohamed sy il a réussi le
tout directement savoir ce matin il fait
très bien
je vis très bien mais vous le jt à la
chasse je suis parti avec mon physique
j'étais là bringuebalant 5 à vos petites
âmes je marche j'ai marché dans la
combine d'accord avec ce que tu vas dire
encore que bêtise effet tout d'un coup
voilà tu sais ce que je vois où un lion
ben tu vois un lion vim
tu vois un lion qui croient le lion il
te vois aussi oui les lions elle me voit
mais moi ou avec mes petites papattes
j'y mets à courir
et alors les lions c'est là les papattes
il court derrière toi le ceto et il fait
oui mais moi ou les chiens marde
il fait les liens et la d'izieu espèce
de bible du brel que tu écris été frappé
tellement dire qu'on est la deuxième a
vu l'armée si oui mais moi je grimpe une
heure il y aura des griffes si le
principe hier
c'est le monde dans la rue peut-être
habile de bouffe oui mais moi je suis
allé au bout de la branche il est allé
au bout de leur rejet d'un travail
bouffe et annick est c'est comme ça
effet oui mais moi je suis tombé de
lundi président tout et je me suis
cachée sur la terre oui mais les murs il
t'a vu le sol de la belle te bouffe le
deal vert lime et homme si brillant
[Applaudissements]